aber meine lieben seminar ist davon
wollen uns natürlich nicht unterkriegen
lassen wir fliegen durch das hallo ich
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen app folge bla
bla bla bla bla wo ich im spiel antesten
ich habs jetzt mal mit ein bisschen
anderen taktik probiert ich habe jetzt
nämlich ein programm runter geladen was
reflektor heißt und hab das mit mit dem
ipad genommen hab das alles verbunden
und ich hoffe die qualität stimmt und
wir spielen heute ein sehr cooles spiel
von dem entwickler der außerdem auch
flecki bereit gemacht hat spielt nämlich
swing koppers und es geht darum dass man
so ein kleines männchen hat mit dem
propeller den kopf und wenn man auf dem
bildschirm drauf drückt dann hat er die
richtung der fig nach links und wieder
nach rechts wenn wir darauf den mann
wieder drauf ich nach links und man muss
quasi sich diese tore durch und ich
würde sagen wir fahren direkt an mit dem
spielen und das spiel ist genauso
aggressiv machen die flippers so hier
ist unser kleiner typ get ready so
klickt man mal ganz kurz drauf und jetzt
müssen wir hier durch diese tore
passiert ja ja ja ja das reflektiert war
es bei mir auch am anfang muss oder dass
ich was mache bei flat byrd war es bei
mir am anfang auch so dass ich so total
ausgerastet bin bei jedem tor danach
ging es einigermaßen und dann bin ich
immer noch ausgelacht als dann
weitergekommen
ihr seht schon mein highscores 1 wenn
ihr das schafft dann seid ihr schon
besser hitzig youtube in ihr wollt könnt
ihr mal wieder euren highscore in die
kommentare schreiben allerdings bitte
nicht so wie unter der letzten flirt vor
also nicht so wie unsere letzten fredy
barth folge weil darin geschrieben hab
23 millionen geschäft blabla freunde ich
hab's im urin das wird mein lauf
ich werde schaffen da ist die 1 jetzt
schweigen
ich war grad sagen ich brauche
eigentlich glaube ich einfach nur musik
aber es bringt nichts vielleicht ein
anderes lied kommt wenn man sich so ein
bisschen konzentriert ich bin ja let's
play an
ich kommentiere das jetzt einfach mal so
ein bisschen nebenbei also ich sags so
ein bisschen was warum fängt dieses
spiel an ohne das okay let's try and
display haben dingsbums blick hier
natürlich kommen da will ich eine slow
motion das hab ich dadurch geschafft
oder so wir schaffen das jetzt meine
lieben freunde wir spielen hier das neu
aber davon wollen uns natürlich nicht
unterkriegen eine liebens terminators
wir spielen hier das neue spiel von dem
wir in diesem entwickler von flirt der
auch diese wundervolle flap flap gemacht
hat mein highscore ist zwei das ist
schon ein wundervoller fortschritt und
wir wollen es natürlich nicht dadurch
unterkriegen lassen dass wir das hier
nicht meine lieben terminiert dass wir
schaffen das natürlich normal sondern da
dran und dann schaffen wir also ich muss
echt sagen dieses spiel ist schlimmer
als flirt ich muss das wirklich sagen
dieses verdammte spiel regt mich gerade
mehr auf als flip wie wird das erst mal
meine fresse facto schütt
das war meine suppen schade ich ja immer
noch den nachklang von der suppe schale
gerade sehr witzig so kommen aber ich
muss das so wisst ihr die sache ist ich
flieg dadurch den ich denke so kommt man
gehe ich noch mal nach links mit ist
leichter da durchgeht und anmutig
dämpfer fall dagegen kam eine tonspur
total ausrasten alte let's try again
mehr so voll weh getan gerade alter
losgeht beim ball um ball um ball um
ball aber meine lieben terminator star
von wollen uns natürlich nicht
unterkriegen lassen wir fliegen durch
dass die katen hier irgendwie kaputt
gebrochen oder irgendwie sowas ich
bräuchte es einen ball den ich einfach
werfen kann oder so wenn ich irgendwas
aufregte aber meine lieben wir machen
das jetzt mal ganz schnell ganz schnell
durch war noch ein kleines mädchen aber
natürlich dass ich also mein ziel für
diese folge ist drei okay ich spiele es
so lange bis ich drei haben schon flap
flap nicht sein alter wie kann man denn
noch in diesem match play zimmer einer
wie oft ich geschrieben habe oder wie
oft ich komme also wenn man unseren
jetzigen score gerade mit der zwei
multipliziert multipliziert agiert hat
man ab das war so knapp das war so
unfassbar knapp was passiert wenn ich da
drauf gucke remove at&t kommt nicht lass
mal
wir wollen natürlich die werbung ist
wichtig wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr auch
mal bei mir die werbung anschauen oder
draufklicken weil dadurch verdienen
leute die so etwas machen ihr geld und
ich find's cool
die app ist natürlich scheiße aber sie
hat fast sie hat was es muss echt sagen
die also das design des echten school
ich liebe solche pigs liegen spiele die
nicht in die richtung gehen wie andere
spieler deswegen ich war kurz sagen ich
hab ein gutes gefühl war dann wohl nicht
so setzen jetzt mal ein bisschen
aufrechter hierhin und halt das ding mal
in der hand vielleicht klappt's ja jetzt
okay leute ich setze ein anderes ziel
das video soll unter zehn minuten
bleiben eigentlich weil ich keinen bock
aber dass solche videos erlang werden
ich muss jetzt diese drei schaffen das
ist mein ziel hat ein ziel ich glaube
ich muss einfach wieder diese ziele
formel in mein gedächtnis reinbekommen
jetzt bin ich wenn mein ziel so la la la
la la la
mach dir nichts draus luca du warst ja
nur einen kleinen millimeter vor der 3
leute ich lasse es sein wenn es euch
gefallen hat last normen hoch da ein
versuch mache ich noch einen verdammten
versuch schreibt mir bitte jetzt in die
kommentare was eure highscores bleibt
das video wenn ihr mehr über reviews
volt und ich muss natürlich immer noch
ein bisschen gut sein hier bisschen gut
ein bisschen freundlich zu euch einen
versuch zum abschluss das ist mein
letzter versuchen die drei zu planen
wenn ich jetzt die drei knacke dann
kommen die nächsten vier tage jeden tag
zwei videos so kann ich jetzt gesagt